turkey says an agreement has been
reached with russia to allow ukraine to
resume exports of grain through the
black sea russian defense minister
sergey shoigu is on route to turkey to
sign the deal and ukraine's
infrastructure ministers also expected
to attend the ceremony
the world shortage of ukrainian grains
since russia's invasion has left
millions at risk of hunger more than 20
million tons of grain are stuck in silos
in the black sea ports of ukraine the
deal to unblock the exports is the first
major accord between the two warring
sides
now let's bring in dw correspondent
julia han who is joining us from
istanbul julia
a deal on grain exports
is expected to be signed today what more
can you tell us
well there has been a growing sense of
urgency to find a solution that would
finally allow ukraine to reopen its
black sea ports and resume grain exports
grain exports that as you mentioned are
urgently needed because the world faces
shortages and higher food prices so the
united nations and turkey have been
trying for weeks now to broker a deal a
compromise between moscow and kiev so
this is a un-led process but ankara's
role is also quite interesting the
turkish government has good relations
with both ukraine and russia they have
offered to mediate in this war in fact
they have performed a quite delicate
balancing act between russia and the
west but they have managed to bring
delegations from both countries together
here in turkey there has been a round of
grain talks last week here in istanbul
on a technical level and if not derailed
at the last minute a deal will be signed
here today in this building right behind
me the dolma bacha palace in istanbul
later in the afternoon the signing will
be attended by turkish president
rejected erdogan and u.n
secretary general antonio guterres
now that deal what will it look like do
we know any
the details details of this deal have
not been made public yet but we do know
that security is a top issue for the
ukrainian government a ukrainian foreign
ministry spokesperson
said that
the ukrainian delegation would only
accept a solution that guarantees the
safety of its southern regions and the
secure export of its agricultural
products so russia would have to make a
promise a credible one not to attack
ukrainian ports and cargo ships the deal
also provides for the creation of a u.n
run
control center here in istanbul at the
strategic location
near the black sea
where brain exports would be overseen
the two sides have reportedly also
agreed on
inspecting
ships that are going to ukraine coming
from ukraine to make sure there are no
weapons or other military equipment on
board that's been a russian demand what
is less clear is right now
how and if ukraine would have to demine
its ports and what compromise has been
found on moscow's demand to ease
restrictions on russian exports of food
and fertilizers
now both sides have been at least
publicly very quiet about this deal are
there any doubt it will come to pass
well uh this deal if signed would be one
of the most significant compromises
reached between moscow and kiev in this
conflict so far there is just so much at
stake the united nations have repeatedly
warned of a global hunger crisis
affecting particularly countries in the
middle east and africa who depend on
ukrainian uh grain the turkish president
interestingly said any uh deal as soon
as it's reached a plan could be put into
action other have others have cautioned
that it might actually take a couple of
weeks to get ukrainian grain exports
going but then there is of course a
difference between what's written down
and signed on a piece of paper and the
situation the realities on the ground we
know the ukrainian government has
accused russia of intensifying strikes
on ukrainian cities in recent weeks so
what will be key at the end is of course
the implementation of this deal
our correspondent julia honda reporting
from istanbul thank you julia
well earlier i spoke with dw
correspondent fanny facial in kiev she
had more on that deal on grain exports
between ukraine and russia
well most of these reports are actually
coming from turkey turkey really tries
to brand itself as the main mediator
here because they were they are the ones
that announced yesterday the presidency
office there that a deal is going to be
signed later this afternoon in istanbul
now we do not know the exact details of
this deal also we didn't hear anything
from russia so far about this deal and
ukraine was also a little bit how should
i say uh um
not very clear on whether a deal is
going to be signed just saying that they
expect some news coming out of turkey
today what we do know looking back what
happened last week uh the these
discussions among ukrainian russian
officials brokered via un and also
turkey to agree on some sort of a
ceasefire because obviously without the
ceasefire it's impossible to get those
vessels full of grains through safe
corridors but this is the big question
here actually if an agreement is put
into a written format whether all these
counterparts can agree on that in
practical terms whether ceasefire can
actually uh be maintained or even
starting in the sports like odessa or
mikko live as well because these are key
portal towns in regions that are heavily
shelled and bombed by russian forces so
a lot of things remain sketchy while at
the same time of course people are
hopeful here in ukraine because
exporting that grain would not only mean
that you can ease the food crisis but
also of course you can make money that
ukraine needs in order to continue this
war and to uh have a have a
yeah a chance in this war against
russian forces
funny thursday left the distinct
impression russia was broadening the
scope of its attacks once more but
president zielinski says that ukrainian
troops are gaining momentum
what's your read from there
there are different ways to look at this
if you are zooming on the donbass region
for example there is a lot of shelling
going on especially when you look at
towns like chroma trucks or bachmud
which are quite close to sloveyansk
which is a very very important town it
is ukrainian controlled basically the
administrative center of the donetsk
region and this is exactly where russian
forces would like to move into because
as you may remember neighboring luhansk
region there the town cerro donetsk was
the key center to take in to actually
control the entire luhansk region so
we're going to hear a lot more about
slovenians in the coming days but also
about all that indiscriminate shelling
that we've been seeing in the report for
example in hakeef region at the same
time yes it seems like ukrainian forces
also do have a momentum given by western
weapons supplies especially the high
mars they have a range of 50 km of 80
kilometers and can strike various uh
supply chains of russia we have to see
how this develops certainly the war in
ukraine is at a turning point
dw correspondent funny for sure thank
you
you